[Musique]
bonsoir mes chers petits amis soir nous
ne sommes pas venus voir petit louis et
mirabel hier soir pour les punir d'avoir
été méchant avec gros ours
vous vous souvenez pourquoi il me veut
de chirée mon beau colmar alors tu peux
leur téléphoner nounours demande l'heure
s'ils sont sages ce soir à nous à nos
loulous
alweendo merabet le petit louis dépenses
à des ponts ulysse demande si vous avez
été sages promet donne moi le téléphone
le nours merci bon et bien puisque vous
avez été sages
je m'en vais vous raconter une belle
histoire mais gros ours ne descendra pas
vous voir ce soir
il viendra demain si vous allez sagement
vous coucher d'accord d'accord d'accord
il y avait une fois dans un joli chant
plein de fleurs et de hautes herbes
un joli me plains d'abeilles et de
petits bourdon qui faisait rond quand
ils volaient il y avait un mignon petit
bourdon qui disait toujours je voudrais
aller dans une étoile
je voudrais aller dans une étoile
et voilà qu'un jour d'une boum boum
comme une balle qui tombait rebondi
plusieurs fois une petite étoile tomba
dans le champ mais en tombant elle se
casse à et s'ouvrit et dedans dormez la
plus jolie petite abeille qu'on ait
jamais vu
elles étaient toutes dorées comme le
miel est petit petit
quand elle se réveilla elle fut très
étonnée de se trouver au milieu de
fleurs entouré de bourdons et d'abeilles
qu'elle ne connaissait pas ses nouveaux
amis furent très gentil pour elle et lui
fit à visiter le pays
le petit bourdon ne la quittait pas il
était plein d'admiration envers une
demoiselle abeilles en provenance d'une
étoile et il volé ensemble de fleur en
fleur
mais la petite abeille était triste car
elle avait l'habitude de vivre au milieu
des étoiles et elle voulait retourner
voir sa maman qui habitait dans une
grande étoile et ses frères et soeurs
qui habitait de petites étoiles et un
jour qu'il dormait posé sur un
coquelicot ronron le petit bourg dont
amena tous ses amis et prenant le
coquelicot chacun par un pétale il
s'envolèrent très vite dans le ciel pour
aller tout en haut
au pays des étoiles
[Musique]
la paix tout agréé retrouve à toute sa
famille qui adopta ronron le petit
bourdon qui avait toujours rêvé de vivre
au milieu des étoiles
[Musique]
oh merci pour la belle histoire lice
bonne nuit qui marchandent sable on est
menés nord fatma
[Musique]
les p'tits louis bony mirabel
bonne nuit à tous les enfants allez vite
vous couchez embrasser bien fort vos
parents et faites de beaux rêves
à demain demain
e
[Musique]